>> Will: YOU KNOW, POLICIES HAVE
CONSEQUENCES.
AND THE QUALITY OF LIFE IN
AMERICA'S BIG CITIES IS SO BAD
THAT IT IS SURPASSING THE
ABILITY OF PARTISANSHIP TO
SUBMIT OR TO HIDE THE TRUTH.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE FED UP
WITH THESE POLICIES.
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN LOS
ANGELES.
IT'S PLAGUED BY CRIME AND
RAMPANT HOMELESSNESS ACCORDING
TO FORMER MAYOR.
BLAMING HIS SUCCESSOR SAYING I
HAVE NEVER SEEN THIS TOWN SO
DIRTY.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN CRIME UP SO
QUICKLY.
THE SPREAD OF HOMELESSNESS, I
THINK, TO MANY ROME IS BURNING.
NEW YORK IS BURNING, TOO.
BUT THE CITY COUNCIL HERE HAS
OTHER PRIORITIES LIKE REMOVING A
STATUE OF THOMAS JEFFERSON AND
DECLARING RACISM A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
JOINING ME NOW TO BREAK DOWN
THIS LUNACY THE POLICY BRIT HUME
FOX NEWS SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST.
BRIT, I GUEST WE CAN REST EASY
THE NEW YORK POLITICIANS HAVE
THEIR POLICIES IN THE RIGHT
PLACE MURDER UP, JEFFERSON
STATUES DOWN.
>> THAT'S THE IDEA, YOU KNOW,
THIS CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS A
GREAT MOVEMENT AT ONE TIME.
IT WAS ABOUT TEARING DOWN
BARRIERS AND NOW TO MUCH OF THE
TIME IT IS ABOUT TEARING DOWN
STATUES.
DOING THAT, TEARING DOWN A
STATUE OR MOVING IT OUT OF SIGHT
OR WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO IS
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE LIFE OF
ONE KID IN HARLEM OR NEW YORK OR
ANYWHERE ELSE.
THESE ARE EMPTY GESTURES.
DESIGNED TO FAN THE FLAMES OF
RACIAL DISAGREEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT WHEN YOU GET
DOWN TO IT, WILL, YOU WERE SO
RIGHT THROUGHOUT MOST OF THIS
BROADCAST.
IT IS ABOUT THE COLLAPSE OF
INDIVIDUAL RESPONSIBILITY, WHICH
WAS SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
INTEGRAL TO AMERICA'S GROWTH AND
PROSPERITY AND NOW WE SEE PEOPLE
IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
CRIMINALS ARE NOT REALLY TO
BLAME.
IT'S THE POLICE FORCE.
AND, YOU KNOW, CRIMES GO
UNPUNISHED, UNARRESTED.
YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
WALKING OUT OF WALGREEN'S STORES
IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH TONS OF
MATERIAL AND SELLING IT ON THE
STREET AND ALL THAT UNPUNISHED.
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT
THE ORDER OF THE DAY.
>> Will: YOU KNOW, BRIT, AS I
WAS LISTENING TO YOU I STARTED
THINKING ABOUT THIS I THIS I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS LATER
THIS WEEK TON "FOX NEWS
PRIMETIME."
THESE ROLLING STATE OF
EMERGENCIES, I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY STATES ARE LIVING UNDER A
STATE OF EMERGENCY, MOST BECAUSE
OF COVID, BUT TO SEE THE NEW
YORK POLITICIANS DECLARE RACISM
A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS, IT'S NOT
JUST A REFLECTION OF THEIR
PRIORITIES, INCREASINGLY IT WILL
BE A POWER CENTER SOURCE FOR
THEM.
IF IT'S AN EMERGENCY, ALL
MEASURES ARE WORTHWHILE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT WHAT THESE POLITICIANS ARE
DOING, THEY ARE EXPLOITING
REALLY THE DECENCY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHICH RESPONDED
TO THE SITUATION IN THIS COUNTRY
WHERE RACISM WAS MUCH TOO
PREVALENT AND PERSISTED LONG
AFTER THE SLAVES WERE FREED AND
AMERICA AS A NATION STOOD UP,
TOOK NOTICE OF THAT AND MADE
MAJOR, MAJOR CHANGES.
WELL WHICH HAVE OPENED DOORS OF
OPPORTUNITY THROUGHOUT THE LAND,
THROUGHOUT SOCIETY, REALLY.
AND IT CHANGED -- AND IT TOUCHED
THE CONSCIENCE OF THE NATION.
AMERICANS DON'T BELIEVE RACISM
IS A TERRIBLE THING AND BEING A
CALLED A RACIST ONE OF THE WORST
THINGS IT CAN HAPPEN.
IT HAS BECOME A POWER FRONT
SCRUPULOUS POLITICIANS HAVE
EXPLOITED IT EVER SINCE AND
CONTINUED TO.
BY KEEPING THE ISSUE ALIVE, THEY
KEEP A SOURCE OF POWER FOR
THEMSELVES ALIVE.
>> Will: AND THEY KEEP THE
DECLINE OF AMERICAN CITIES IN A
PERPETUAL STATE OF TRAGEDY,
MURDER, CRIME, HOMELESSNESS, ALL
ON THE RISE WHILE THEY BATTLE
THIS DON KEY HUMANE SOCIETIY
WIND MILL OF ACCUMULATING MORE
POWER FOR THEMSELVES.
BRIT, I THINK IT'S THE FIRST
TIME WE HAVE TALKED.